الى تركيا حيث اكد الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
ان انتخابات الرئاسه والبرلمان ستجرى في
موعدها في الرابع عشر من مايوير المقبل
واشار في كلمه امام كتلته البرلمانيه الى
ان هناك من يحاول استغلال الزلزال لاغراض
سياسيه كما حذر اردوغان في الوقت ذاته من
ان المنطقه ستمر بعاصفه من الزلازل التي
يجب الاستعداد لها وفق تعبيره واشار الى
ان الشعب من خلال الانتخابات سيرد على من
وصفهم بالشامتين
هناك مغرضون يفرحون لرؤيه ما اسفرت عنه
الزلازل ظنا منهم ان الحكومه والدوله
والشعبه سيقعون تحت هذه الانقاض لكن على
هؤلاء الذين لم يذهبوا لمنطقه الزلازل ولم
يزوروا المنكوبين ان يعلموا ان الشعب
التركي سيرد على هؤلاء المغربين في الرابع
عشر من مايو ايار المقبل والشعب التركي لن
يابها لمن يرددون الشعارات والمقولات
الفارغه